Before we start creating particles using Niagara fluids, I'd like us to have a quick overview
look at the system to better understand exactly what it is that the system offers us and what
kind of fluids we can make with the Niagara Fluids plugin.
So first off, what are Niagara fluids?
Well when we say Niagara fluids, what we're actually talking about is a tool set for creating
real time liquids.
This tool set was designed to be artist friendly and we're going to find that it includes a
variety of GP based simulators, reusable modules, and robust data structures that are all accessible
within the Niagara editor.
We can use all of these various Niagara components to build different 2D and 3D versions of real
time fluids and gases and fires that you might find in the real world.
The reason we want to use Niagara fluids is actually most of the work is done for you.
Since we are trying to recreate a physical phenomena, all we really have to do is just
adjust a few values and most of the heavy lifting or underlying work has already been
done for us and what we're going to get is a really, really efficient 2D or 3D version
of whatever smoke or liquid or fire we're trying to simulate.
Now whatever we are trying to simulate, we're going to find that there are different versions.
There's a 2D gas, a 2D liquid, a 3D gas, a 3D liquid, and shallow water and each one
of these are going to be utilized for something slightly different.
The 2D gas is where flow only occurs in the X and the Y dimension.
This is really suited for real time simulations and while it might only be a 2D representation,
it can interact with geometry and the characters.
One other thing to note about the 2D gas and 2D flip is that the simulations do face the
camera so that no matter where the camera is pointed, it's always going to align with
the camera making them good for things like fire or a water effect.
Now our 3D gas is going to be the most common type of simulation used to simulate gas or
fire or smoke.
However, it is going to have a much more complex or higher memory and GPU cost and therefore
it's best used for hero effects in real time applications or for cinematics.
We can bake the results of these into textures which we'll talk about in a little bit, but
if you want to make heavy use of these, remember that it's going to be very expensive in terms
of memory and GPU memory.
Now the 2D flip stands for fluid implicit particle and it's simply referring to how
the particle system is set up behind the scenes which you don't need to talk about right now.
The difference between the 2D flip and the 3D flip is this.
The 2D flip samples 3D particles but it generates a 2D simulation where pressure is solved and
applied to the particles giving it a 3D look but at a 2D cost.
The 3D flip on the other hand is simulating full 3D water interaction allowing you to interact
with the water with the character or static mesh and the water will then move up and around
just as water would in the real world.
Actually very very interesting and great particle to mess with and we'll see that here in just
a little bit.
Now the 3D flip you might think would be something that we would use maybe all over for all types
of different bodies of water and unfortunately while it is good at some things it is not
good at other things and that is where the shallow water comes in.
Now the shallow water is useful for simulating pools of water that don't contain many splash
effects.
This could be also used to simulate things like boatwakes or simple interactions with
objects moving through the water.
So again the type of fluid that we pick is going to depend on the situation at hand so
we don't necessarily need to always use a 3D gas or a shallow water or a 3D flip.
We can use combinations of 2D gases and 3D gases and 3D flips and 2D flips and we'll
see how all of this gets put together in the next couple of slides.